we've come out of an economic crisis and
global economies have not recovered to
the extent that you would have expected
we've got a lot of countries all of whom
have ailing economies and all of whom
see boosting exports through a weaker
currency as a panacea almost we've got a
currency war and there's no two ways
about that you have the European Central
Bank which is trying to introduce easier
monetary policy and that produces a
weaker euro people don't want to be in
the Europe so where do they go they go
to the Swiss franc suddenly you have the
Swiss franc strengthening Swiss central
bank doesn't want that to happen doesn't
want say yet exports can't so it then
implements policies to try and weaken
its currency in Sweden entered the wall
and it's cut its its interest rates to
negative it is desperately trying to
weaken the kroner next in the crosswise
two Danish kroner and on it goes there's
a race to the bottom and what you're
effectively doing when you devalue your
currency is you're stealing exports for
your ladies the most straightforward and
direct way is you turn on your printing
presses you print your own currency and
then you go and sell it in the open
market against some other currency you
buy Euros or you buy dollars the second
way is through interest rates if you
make your interest rates negative you
are charging for the privilege of
holding your currency the nuclear option
and any currency war is something called
capital controls and the way you do it
is you impose taxes and levies on on
people trying to move currency in and
out of your country if these currency
wars persist I really do think that in
the coming weeks or months you'll start
to see more and more talk about capital
controls it's a silent war because it's
kind of an admission of failure if
you're the citizen of a country that's
weakening its currency that oversees
holiday you have fun to take that just
got a lot more expensive citizens one of
the in countries that seem strong that
can talk big and now have growth
economies and if you
currencies weakening it's certainly
gonna give everyone the impression that
you know what you're not such a great
country unfortunately one of the things
about the currency market is you have to
trade in pairs and so not everyone can
be weaker than everyone else's
the big victim in this is the US the
dollar has been strengthening massively
in the past year and you're starting to
hear squeals of pain from US companies
companies like Microsoft even Apple the
world's biggest company now have said
listen we are here ting because of this
because strong dollars crimping our
earnings and we don't like it the u.s.
is carrying the burden of the global
economic recovery and there's a strong
argument that says you know what that is
not fair
problem with war is nobody wins in the
end you can have periods of of the upper
hand the ascendency but the US it's the
world's largest economy still and at
some point I think it is going to say
enough is enough and it's going to start
trying to talk down the dollar and you
would hope that other countries have got
a better growth outlook than that
they'll be able to cope with that
reversal even when it comes it doesn't M
well this movie I've seen it before it
always ends badly